John Heilemann is managing editor
Bloomberg politics and co-host of the
circus on Showtime a division of CBS
John good morning hi hi
quite a weekend yes I would after quite
a week so what impact does it have on
this race
well Josh and I were discussing this
just earlier to share with us I think if
you I think if you fly it you know you
got it you can get down in the weeds on
the story or you can just think about it
this way
Donald Trump's behind in this race he's
never been ahead and he needs to gain
ground he needs to gain votes all of
last week he didn't advance his cause in
that direction at all and now this story
is gonna consume at least the next week
where he's going to be defending himself
there gonna be new details on the taxes
there's gonna be new questions about his
temperament because of how he's behaving
in his rallies he's gonna be explaining
and defending rather than pushing
forward and advancing his cause at least
until the next debate and there aren't
that many days left between now and
Election Day it's we're down to like now
36 37 news cycles if you lose six or
seven of them how do you get to be
President but his surrogates like
Giuliani and Chris Christie are using
the word genius describe this it
possibly worked in his advantage look I
get that there gonna be a lot of people
on Wall Street and who are gonna say you
know well he worked within the law and
this is probably smart use of the tax
laws I just as hard for me to believe
that in a lot of battleground states
with a lot of ordinary people that they
think he lost 900 not nearly a billion
dollars and then managed to use that
that's yeah I think that's access how
does that make commit a genius that's
exactly right yeah that's the point that
major was making yeah I mean what kind
of bad business decisions cause you to
make not to lose 916 billion the
mid-1990s at the time of the greatest
economic boom in our recent memory and I
just do think for a lot of people there
will be two different ways the Clinton
campaign wants to attack Donald Trump
one to say look he's not really a great
businessman at all
look at all the money he lost and two
he's a tax cheat and both of those are
tendentious claims there were their
responses you could make you for Donald
Trump and his surrogates but for a lot
of ordinary voters that'll be it we'll
plant that seed of light well that sort
of seems like that and he's also
funky and he also said again this
weekend I'm the only one who can fix it
but it's never seemed as though Donald
Trump that this
this man has ever had any problem with
the tax code if Donald Trump had wanted
to make the argument that he's a change
agent and put his tax returns out and
say you know what this system stinks
here's the way in which eyes exploited
the system here are all the things that
would do to change it that would be bad
for me that's how much of a change agent
I am and go into the details of how he
did it that could be a really powerful
political thing to do look he has
exhibited no interest in releasing his
tax returns and Herbert has resisted
calls now for the better part of a year
so it would be a huge turnabout if he
were to go out and do that but that's
the way in which this all this could
have been to his advantage
I've know no one who knows the system
I'm known to commit in fact it's got to
be more disclosed evict argue in fact
that's the kind of ardent he made during
the primaries when it talked about how
much money he'd given to politicians
right and how much influence he gained
because of it right and I get I say we
still don't know so much because of the
fact that we don't have his tax returns
if he again he could make this argument
but he would have to really do it in a
very it'd be a very bold move for him to
do it at this juncture and then he
criticizes people who have not paid
their taxes who have made a lot of money
yes I can imagine there are some hedge
fund folks who he says attacked for not
paying their taxes I might be feeling a
bit chagrin hey guys morning just a
touch thank you John thank you guys CBS
News will bring you live coverage of the
vice presidential debate tomorrow
beginning at 9:00 Eastern 8:00 central
here's a look inside the debate a Hall
at Virginia's Longwood University Elaine
Quijano of our streaming network cbsn
will be the moderator